[Music]
for we want to establish an amazing
Masjid for the sake of Allah subhana
tala in the country of Norway click on
the link and donate now for the sake of
Allah subhana tala you say Netflix and
and I'm going to say no it's Netflix and
burn okay
yeah brothers and sisters and dear
friends I've got amazing news for you
guys absolutely phenomenal it's going to
bring coolness to your heart your day is
going to change you know that drink you
drink that lemonade is going to be extra
cool for you m why because we are going
to be talking about a scum dirt bag
criminal a filthy everything that you
can add together yes has been
neutralized
liquidated yes in liquidation okay yes
uh so usually I don't watch Netflix some
people do Netflix and chill this guy
he's probably a walker who's dead he's
probably doing Netflix and burn now in
Janam oh damn inshallah so tell us about
this movie it's called f foda foda so
foda what does that mean it means chaos
like chaos yeah so chaotic thing
happening a chaotic thing happening just
like uh what happened to him in the end
okay what come to what happened to him
in the movie what's what is he is an
actor cuz he's now is you know Superman
hero so what's what's his acting role in
this chaotic movie I mean the thing with
these Israeli IDF people is you don't
know if I mean they're they're actors in
real life the baby killers in real life
actually the actors also in real life
life and their actors also in movies you
actually can't tell the difference
between both of them you can't they're
both liar Li yeah so in this movie folda
which means chaos he's an IDF Soldier or
there are IDF soldiers that go after
this Rogue Palestinian Hamas ironically
and they happily blow up um Palestinian
homes and the likes so yeah so his name
his name is Anan amedi amedi yeah so
whatever his name is I mean uh he's
called the bodyy now yeah or maybe bodyy
back yeah he is a body back now so he
was fantasizing about you know blowing
up Palestinian homes and you know
pretending and doing this a sick person
would do anyway agree to so would you
agree to me it's like someone said to
him you're going to be this in this
acting role and you're going to be doing
this and he's thinking yeah you know and
give him a fake gun cuz that's the best
he can live they're not real soldiers
yeah they can't they're coward yeah they
only do Tik Tok videos and acting so he
was probably Gass and then when this
whole thing happened he thought let me
go cuz it's going to be probably like
acting he was gassed up in it and then
yeah may Allah preserve and bless him in
uh
so anyways uh so he thought it's going
to be like an acting serious you know
when the camera says cut it cuts and
he's like okay look let me do that
shooting scene again but in real life it
doesn't work like that because um the
resistant Fighters the Palestinians were
talking about of course for that matter
um they don't tell you cut or repeat
that again no they cut they cut the
scene and they repeat the cut they cut
the
scene there no scene though did they say
cut the shot
there's no shot there bro he cut the
shot they take the shot yeah so anyway
they cut the flesh so where is this uh
war criminal now is he is he disabled
now is he yeah I mean there's mixed
reports I leg or arm some say know yeah
he disabled some say he's with PTSD some
say some say he's dead crial some say
he's been burning I don't know there's
various reports I I hope he's not dead I
hope he's he's disabled yeah because
it's it's funny you mentioned that
because one of the Israeli officials let
me just uh no please go go go find them
please find the official in the meantime
let me just talk a bit about this weasel
this because you know you know why it's
important is because this actually ties
in well with the Israeli Heritage
Minister who said that there should be
ways more powerful than death for the
Palestinians so people that might be
thinking oh what what they saying we're
actually going in line with uh with the
what the is Israeli hups are saying and
we're just regular YouTubers but these
people are creating the policy that's
facilitating a genocide live televised
for people to see and would we ever W
that on innocent civilians oh never
never for that matter let's make that
very clear because this this SC said
this he's talking about innocent
Palestinian kids and under international
law you can I mean they they a Target
exactly so what we're saying is for that
matter you're talking about the idea of
soldiers yeah yes so what we're saying
in The Nut Show is we want Palestine to
be returned back to the Palestinians
where the Jews Christians and Muslims
lived like they did for many centes we
do not want the killing of any inant
people for that matter but scum Dirtbag
in Netflix who's getting um excited
about killing Palestinians for that
matter who goes and joins a real army
and knows what time it is yeah he's now
in critical condition yes physically
emotionally spiritually in every angle
his legs are probably missing from
either sides inshallah so yes and I
think it was well deserved I think this
is this was Netflix and burn yes you
know you can't expect to go swimming
without getting wet he went swimming he
got wet I mean he got more than he
bargain for I mean there's 200 Indians
that are popped over there four of them
have been liated yeah they they've gone
there you got British soldiers you know
British IDF people from this country
going there they're being liquidated if
you want to go you want to get
liquidated they no problem I mean that's
that's up to you you I don't know where
this term came from but it sounds um it
sounds interesting maybe it's from the
analogy of the swimming pool that I gave
about liquid and stuff like that yeah I
don't know maybe that's unconscious like
a banking term as well like you know
liquidation of assets in this matter
they're worthless assets they've been
liquidated yeah um I hope the
liquidation continues um we want more
liquidations of these individuals these
war criminals it's inevitable yes it's
inevitable and uh may Allah strengthen
the liquid Liquidators if that's even
grammatically I think they'll have to
update the O dictionary now yes yes in N
nice SC thank you brother do you like
mine not really thank
you brother sisters to next
time goodbye color color Liquidator
it's a color we we that's
Liquidator yes okay so next time brother
sisters hope this has brought peace to
your heart and just something to add on
which is an icing on the cake 12 and a
half thousand of them are also uh one
with another disabled one or another may
Allah increase those numbers in yeah why
is this the color of we we um cuz we're
talking about the Liquidators okay so
all connected you see join the
dots I don't want to be around the bush
have you heard of the savima Norway
Masjid project your brothers and sisters
at Islam net are establishing a one-of
its kind mid da and Community Center in
the capital of Norway and they need our
urgent support now every person that
accepts Islam through this Center every
revert who learns about their Dean and
calls their family to the worship of
Allah subhana wa tala you will get the
rewards inshallah so here's what you
must do you must contribute to get your
rewards and share this project imagine
you meeting Allah subhana wa tala and
receiving the glad ing of a palace in
jna because of this very Masid you built
with your Sak now you tell me what
Greater Joy can there be than getting a
house in Jenna with Gardens and rivers
of Honey walls built of bricks of gold
and silver mortar of fragrant musk
Pebbles of Pearl and Sapphire and soil
of saffron and whoever enters a house in
Jenna will be filled with joy and will
never feel miserable they will live
there forever and they will never die
they will get close that will never wear
out and the youth Will Never Fade Away
Subhan Allah these are the descriptions
of the houses in Jenna that our beloved
Prophet peace be upon Him gave to his
beloved companions would you not want
that for your afterlife click the button
to donate and earn this tremendous
reward inshallah and don't forget to
share the
video